Now, let's discuss the solution for the active
power quiz. What we had was that to achieve
some frequency we needed to increase voltage beyond
some point. And we knew that at 1 volt
and 2 gigahertz, the power was 30 watts.
So, the question is, what is the power for
the most power-efficient setting? And, what is the
power for the highest-performance setting? The most power-efficient setting
will be the one with lowest frequency and
the lowest voltage. Why? Because the power, if
you remember, is equal to something times voltage
squared times frequency. So, we need to have,
to reduce power, we need to both lower
the frequency and reduce voltage. So, most power-efficient
setting is this one. Relative to this setting,
the power for the most efficient setting is
going to be equal to, so this stand for our efficient power, is going to
be 30 watts times the voltage is now 0.9 of what it was. So,
it's 0.9 squared times the frequency
now is 1.8 over 2. So this is, again, 0.9
of what it was and when we multiply this out we get 21.9
watts or 22 watts. So, the answer here
is that the power is 21.9 watts. Now let's
do the same, but this time for the highest
performance setting. The highest performance setting is the one
that gives us the highest frequency. What we have
now is the power for the performance is going
to be equal to 30 watts times the voltage is now 1.5 times what it was, so it's
1.5 squared times, the frequency is 3 instead
of 2 gigahertz, so that has also increased by
a factor of 1.5 and if you multiply this out we get 101.3 watts. So, as you can
see, there is a huge difference between the
most power efficient and the highest performance setting. Although,
in fact, the difference between these two settings is
not even a factor of two in performance. Why?
Well, because power is not only
proportional to frequency, it's also proportional
to voltage squared and reusing the frequency allows us to reduce the voltage.